well welcome to the annual mean meeting
of Stratford district council I'd like
to welcome returning councillors new
counselors our guests former chairman
and for the first time the chairman of
work district councils George Airy worth
on neighboring council so welcome to
everybody to this meeting we now move on
to point 1 which is election chair of
the council and I as I am chairman I'll
be stepping down and hand over to the
vice chairman penny and O'Donnell
[Music]
so I call for nominations for chairman
of the Council
I wish to nominate two councillor Carol
thank you do I have a seconder second
any other nominations as there's only
one nomination can I have a show of
hands please those for Thank You those
against and any abstentions
therefore counts Lakota is nominated as
chairman of the Council
hopefully nominated and elected I think
but thank you very much penny on for
that I have two speeches want to
continue in brief and one which is going
to be less brief hopefully this is the
right one firstly I'd like to thank my
chaplain for the last 12 months
Nicki Chaston and I'm very pleased that
she's offered to continue to be chaplain
for me for next for the next 12 months
I'd also like to thank Claire Johnson
who has been the prop and stay of the
churners office the last 12 months and
looking after me I think has been quite
a challenge I'll try and behave better
this time thank you all for giving you
the confidence to give me a second term
as chair of the Council I hope that
those who have worked with me in the
last 12 months will realize that I have
not taken that responsibility lightly
and have been committed to helping drive
this council forward I will continue to
do so on that basis this last year has
been a significant one for the council
we've seen the retirement of too long
serving servants Dave Webb and Chris st.
and the appointment of a new head of
paid service Isabel and twelve months
ago we had a new leader I've been many
highlights in the past year for me in my
role as chairman most importantly the
repeated exposure to volunteers across
the district helping and supporting our
citizens whether to win sporting Musical
or culture Awards helping make our
district a better place or as
importantly supporting those at the
other end of the scale who just need
help to be able to live a reasonable
life
they all deserve our thanks and I'm very
grateful to have seen them doing their
bit the second I think high point was
the publication of the first time of a
role of AMA honor commemorating those
1565 service men and one woman of this
district who died in or shortly after
the First World War
approximately one in six of the adult
male population of the district between
20 and 40
in November in front of an international
audience of 800 delegates some citizen
and the globe Stratford was in void
invited to join the China International
friendship cities conference in Wuhan
and that conference being one of only
four cities invited to address a
conference on the subject of
international city cooperation on the
back of that conference earlier this
month I attended a meeting at the
Chinese embassy and culture and tourism
and have been invited along with Helen
Peters of Shakespeare's England to
addressing conference in Beijing next
month on the same topic when you compare
the size of Stratford as a time with
some of the other great tourism capitals
of the world Paris Rome Vienna Prague
Budapest to name a few you realize that
despite our very modest size and
resources we are punching way above our
weight on the world tourism stage
however given the strength of that
competition it would be easy if we were
to become complacent to fall behind the
interest in sport china has shown us in
the past three years demonstrate that if
we work on our international profile we
can continue to be seated
at the top table that is where we need
to be but nothing comes for it for free
and we need to work together with the
Town Council the birthplace trust the
town trust the RSC our schools and
Shakespeare's England to ensure our
offering to the great global tourist
industry mains world-class and I look
forward to working with Marinero on
Stratford district council I just ran
for Town Council on this we celebrated
our relationship in April with two
things one a conference with a group of
Chinese interested in working together
in the automotive industry and this was
a meeting held at the welcome hotel on
the 26th of April and then secondly the
unveiling of the peony pavilion a gift
from the city of Fujio in Jiangsu
Province in front of a crowd of some 40
Chinese guests including government
ministers from both China and the UK as
well as members of this can be our
community from both within and without
the district on 2nd of May
we lost 17 counselors [ __ ] who are not
returned and with Eric Payne they
represented 244 years of experience as
counselors we now have a new intake of
counselors on behalf of all returning
counselors I'd like to welcome our new
in Texas Council we have a busy schedule
the next four years provide us with some
challenges and opportunities not least
of our challenges is the forecast
funding gap in our budget by the end of
the period of between three and three
and a half million pounds between annual
income and expenditure we need to build
a new corporate strategy for the
district and we need to ensure that we
have a strong focus on the district's
ecological and environmental footprint
we have some great opportunities not
least in that provided by the wells
borne campus of Warrick University
through our university of work we've
been developing excellent relations with
the university over the last 12 months
we look forward to continuing that
process and support this exciting
opportunity we will continue with a
compulsory purchase order of wells borne
airfield as a key plank in the economic
development of this business this fully
functioning facility is a is an
important asset for this district we
will continue to develop relations with
China
now the second biggest economy in the
world and the fastest growing in terms
of both number and spending of tourists
we have begun to work closer with the
Coventry Warren local enterprise
partnership and the West Midlands
combined authority to seize and maximize
the opportunity to attract inward
investment into the into our area we
will need to refresh our core strategy
and we will seek to enhance employment
business and economic development
dimensions of the strategy we believe
that the next four years can ensure our
district continues its seek out its
economic outperformance creating jobs
and prosperity for our residents I
believe the opening on Monday of a new
direct lines children line service from
Stratford to London is a sign of the
future for Stratford ladies and
gentlemen will represent a great
district I look
for working with you all thank you
we now move on to the appointment of the
vice chairman of the council I call for
a nomination for the vice chairman
chairman do I have a nomination any
nomination for him
I nominate Tony Dixon who's vice
chairman do I have a seconder for that
proposal councillor Richards thank you
are there any other nominations
as there is only one nomination can we
confirm with a show of hands our support
for that nomination all those in favor
thank you any against any abstentions in
which case I declare that Tony Dixon is
nominated is elected as the vice
chairman of the council in his absence
we will move forward and I'd now like to
propose a vote of thanks to our retiring
vice chairman council opinion O'Donnell
it was unfortunate Penny's taking on the
role of chairman was to leave some six
months by her knee to look after her
father following an accident however
since taking office in October it's been
a great pleasure to work with penny with
the enthusiasm that she's brought the
job and she's been of great assistance
to me attending those events which has
inevitably happens
I was either double-booked or unable to
attend for other reasons now one can
miss her enthusiasm and her ability to
meet and engage with a wide variety of
individuals and causes we meet through
this this role we've been a very
successful team over the last six months
and penny out very much like to thank
you this was demonstrated I think as we
set off for a carol service in Christmas
in Nuneaton late lost and
penny was still smiling when we got
there despite having to find somewhere
very challenging to park and I think it
shows her support for me in that role so
Thank You penny very much I'd now like
to propose a vote of thanks for
councilor penny on O'Donnell has been
vice chairman do I have a seconder Thank
You councillor Pemberton all those in
favor anyone against Thank You penny and
very much would you like to say a few
words well thank you chairman for your
kind words
so chairman chairman I should say fellow
councillors ladies and gentlemen I would
like to take this opportunity to express
my gratitude to Stratford district
council for asking me to be vice-chair
of this wonderful council over the past
six months thank you especially to
Claire Johnson for your help with
last-minute engagements which I had to
fill in to vice-chair in the st. ena a
year of some women getting the vote I
think was an inspired appointment
councilor kettle and I continually drive
to increase female representation within
our Council I've therefore been thrilled
to have talent supported and supported
and campaigned with and for exciting new
councilors Sarah Walley Coggins being
vice-chair opened up a whole new world
hitherto unknown to me that of the chain
gang not to be confused with the 1960s
hit single by the gifted and inspired
singer Sam Cooke this chain gang
consists of fascinating civic heads from
many beautiful and varied towns and
cities across Warwickshire cross-party
networking where ideas and visions for
our County are shared an opportunity to
remove the cynicism from politics and to
focus on the visions and hopes and
ambition both we and more importantly
our next generation right he deserves I
was honored to celebrate Charities
recognized in the Queen's Birthday
Honours attend elections of high
bailiffs be immersed in covent his rich
program of new writers and International
Women's and Peace Day celebrations
enjoyed Lord lieutenant's and high
sheriff's carol services where Chris
Berg councillor Caitlyn I sang in fine
voice although he did compete with me
during the discounts and more recently
celebrate our Shakespeare birthday
celebrations where Stratford Sean
even in tempest like weather we welcomed
our value Chinese guests to the opening
of the peony pavilion as you've already
mentioned council kettle and a
friendship dinner at a jewel in the
crown of this verdant district Radley
Hall
councillor kettle I wish you continued
success with your China project and its
connection with our rural district and I
look forward to seeing if our stronger
links with China will also lead to
marketing links for the many artists and
businesses within our wards exciting
times are ahead I wish my successor Tony
Dixon a joyful year and I thank you
again for the opportunity to represented
this council
punished
as counsel Nixon that is absence today
I'm proposing that councilor penny on
O'Donnell continues in the seat of
vice-chairman for the rest of the
duration of this meeting
she's one SAP stand up that end when the
chairman was casted off for medical
attention hopefully won't happened today
I'm not planning it but you never know
right I need now to sign my declaration
of office following my nomination and
accept approval whereas whereas my
declaration of office it's not right Sam
of the council 9 2019 2020 declaration
of acceptance of office I Christopher
cattle have been elected to the office
of chairman of the Council of the
District of stratford-upon-avon
hereby declare that I take that office
upon myself and will Julie and
faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability I undertake to be guided by
stratford-on-avon this District
Council's code of members conduct in the
performance of my functions in that
office
[Music]
right we can now move on to point five
on the agenda which is apologies for
absence can I ask the head of paid
service to do this details that of
apologies thank chairman I've received
three apologies from councillor Bromwich
councillor Dixon and councillor Shenton
are there any other apologies okay point
six on the agenda disclosures of
interest
I invite members of the council to make
an indexer it declarations of interest
that they need to the meeting I
therefore move on to the report of the
returning officer
right
well welcoming as I've already mentioned
new counselors to counsel namely
counselors Adam Allcock Cleve Curtis
Dixon headin fitter Fleming Foreman
fragile II in fragile II Harvey Henshaw
Seraphin Jennings Junaid
Riley Rock Shenton and Whaley Hawkins
could those counselors please stand
thank you and welcome to the council I'm
now going to move on to a place on
record a vote of thanks to former
councillors who were not reelected
I have Linda organ sue Adams and just in
Courage the details of their service of
the council are listed I think they're
listed agenda but sue Adams comes first
award just encourage for the samba
landlord and Linda mostly issue of the
bridge town water does anybody wish to
make any comments on those counselors in
which case nope we'll move on we
therefore move on to the election of the
leader of the council please can I have
nominations for the leader of the
council causa Pemberton Thank You chair
I counselor Tony Jefferson do I have a
seconder for that role council cargle
I'd like to second the nomination of
Jefferson thank you do we have any other
nominations in the absence of any other
nominations then can we have a show of
hands in support of the nomination of
coz that council Tony Jefferson as
chairman as leader of the council
all those against the nomination any
abstentions
Tony you are nominated as the leader or
accepted as a leader of the council
congratulations
I'd like you to present your report
please Thank You J what I think already
you have on your table the leader
statement which contains in each the
executive decision-making powers it
contains portfolio holders and their
responsibilities the leader scheme of
delegation to cabinet portfolio holders
8 contains covenant working groups
representation on external strategic
bodies and delegations next term working
in other words it's a very thorough
document nearly all the data that people
need to understand the delegation of a
for executive functions to cabinet and
members of the cabinet is contained in
this Thank You councillor kuna do you
have a yes I wonder if this is
appropriate time for me to to say
something from the leaders statement it
just come to my notice that the National
Audit Office report which was issued on
the 7th of May 2019 identified Coventry
warwickshire lab as the fourth worst in
the country for gender balance so I just
wondered whether this is on the
boardroom and the government has an
expectation for at least one third of
the lepor members to be women by 2020
which is in one year's time so would the
count leader of the council assist this
gender balance balance target by
appointing a woman for from his group to
the let board
lead up
but respondent thank you they let our
very were aware of the need to get
gender balance and working very hard on
it I have to say that actually my
appointment is for three years which is
actually done by the lack and I think it
is entirely appropriate given the nature
of that decision-making body which is
very significant that this council is
represented by the leader of the council
that is the case with all the other
district councils so like I say I think
it is entirely appropriate and the
gender balance issue is being addressed
do we have any other questions for the
leader nope so we then move on to number
four then if any guests would like to
take this opportunity to leave the room
and have some refreshments next door if
they wish
they're very welcome if they wish to
stay for a mini part of the week meeting
there of course equally welcome I'll
give you a minute to stand up and leave
or if you wish
Clare Clare is there to need you out if
you wish if you just depart
okay I think those who are leaving or on
the process of leaving so we'll move on
to point nine we have the or you should
all have in front of you a calculation
of the political balance and membership
of committees I'm going to seek a
proposer and seconder to agree the
political balance calculation of night
20 1920 and the committee composition
for 1920 which is also set out in that
table can I have a professor please
counsel Pemberton are you proposing do I
have a seconder councillor Harris thank
you although councillor Roth may I ask
is there a reason why councillor
Brahmaji is not on any committee I think
I'll hardly leave that to monetary
offset I think my information is
secondhand actually so I would prefer
Lee mr. Buckland thank you thank you yes
so as you'll be aware or group leaders
and members are consulted as to which
committees they would like to sit on
unfortunately councillor formation
couldn't accommodate any of the meat
committees and therefore PRC does isn't
considered for any the committees this
time
any further questions on the political
balance and membership committees we
have a proposer and we have a seconder
then all those in favor of the personal
balance calculation as set out in the
paper in front of you I think that's
unanimous any anybody not in agreement
thank you that is carried we therefore
move on to item 10 which is appointments
to outside bodies it's set out in front
of you and do we have any other
nominations because of Rowlf I think you
were first there could I propose that
Victoria Alcott be put forward for the
Stratford historic building trust from
the Lib Dem go
to what
right
is that the only amendment you have okay
but I propose that councilor kettle is
actually the our nominee for the West
Midlands Reserve forces and cadets do I
have a seconder for that counter stop
Hamilton Thank You councillor Roth I
guess could I ask right there isn't a
stratford-upon-avon markets forum as an
outside body it's not on the current
list we have an outside body before with
three months property on it if we are
going to introduce it can I ask that
there is political parents on that case
they're apparently covered in the legal
statement counts are off would you leave
it to have a paid service to comment hi
so there are different their various
boards one of which is is stated in the
leader statement and that's the markets
forum is covered in that already that
sort the item that's already been
through cancer off following the
counselor to Ned's suggestion of council
all Cockrum what what's it going to be
done about that we will have a vote on
that if I exclude item H at the moment
as there are no other nominations for
items a to Jay excluding H now are we
agreed to accept the nominations
except for H and we will have a separate
vote on H after this so are we happy to
accept those nominations as put forward
in the paper in front of you are we
agreed
anybody have a problem with that okay
that's carried right cancer point eight
we have a nomination of cancer Jeffs has
been put for as being proposed do we
have a second if accounts to the
Jefferson's name Karen stop that
Pemberton yes and cancer cog is a
secondary yeah so we're a proposal and
second of cats Jefferson we got a
proposer for counselor all [ __ ] and a
second to account of role thank you very
much we are do we do this on the show of
hands but all although if you wish to
explain why you want to put cancer
Olcott forward I'm delighted here I'm
sure fellow councillors weren't as well
I think the point is that the this is
covering the Stratford and of somebody
who is or a town council and district
councillor or has knowledge of it but
also I as I understand it councillor
Jefferson is on an awful lot of other
outside bodies and we thought this might
help him thank you can search unit do
you does anybody wish to nominate why or
nominating council Jefferson because
he's the best person for the job
thank house Pemberton right were to go
for a show of hands all those in favor
of councillor Jefferson
all those in favor of counsel okok
[Music]
right it's Kara by Councillor Jefferson
sir Council and Jefferson will be the
counselor pointy on the strap historic
building trust thank you very much as we
drove close to this meeting before then
I announce the next meeting of the
council with the 15th of July in 2019
there is no other business and therefore
I disclose formally close this part of
the meeting thank you ladies and
gentlemen we now move on to the second
stage of the meeting to appoint the
chairman for the council committees and
the council committees that we are need
to appoint the chairman of are as
follows ordered in the standards
committee employment and appointments
committee the overview and scrutiny
committee the planning committee a
planning committee be a regulatory
committee and that are all that's the
end of the committee's we have to
appoint I'm now going to hand over to
the head of page service to report names
those counselors appointed several Thank
You chairman okay can I have the
following counselors please stand when I
call your name sir it's counselor
O'Donnell counselor Foreman counselor
Crump counselor phytic Council Harris
counselor Jennings counselor Rock
counselor Ralph and any of the
substitutes as well please counselor
Cleve councillor Dixon counselor fitter
counselor Junod and Kendall
oh sorry sorry substitutes don't need to
stand aside
cuz I like you
I'm proposing councillor penny Hana DOOL
as chairman of auditing standards oh I'm
sorry
thank you we're gonna propose that and a
seconder for that sorry mr. op but it
has to be a has to be a committee member
of the audience Standards Committee so
we've got causa Harris and castor
foreman is on the committee so this rock
we are there we've got the correct
people yes we got we got we got a
secretary card for Foreman okay
are there any other nominations if there
are no other nominations I please
Commission for show of hands for the
election of counselor O'Donnell as
chairman of audience standards other
members of the committee anyone against
cancer Donnell is elected chairman of
the audience committee
do I have any nominations for Vice Chair
of the committee to stand up any oh can
you please stand up committee members
for audit and standards thank you do I
have any nominations for Vice Chair of
the committee councillor Crump I'd like
to propose performance other is there a
seconder Thank You councillor Jennings
and are there any other nominations
thank you all those in favor could you
please raise your hand hands those
against any abstentions
thank you it's just to note that
counselor jewel Foreman is nominated and
elected as the vice chair of audits and
standards and please note that the next
meeting of the audit and Standards
Committee is scheduled to take place on
Monday the 29th of July thank you mate
you can sit down now okay we'll get this
smoother for this one I think we're now
moving on to the employment and
appointments committee so please could I
have standing councillor Jefferson
councillor Pemberton councillor Allcock
councillor Barker councillor Cleve
councillor phytic councillor
Ian fragile a councillor Harvey please
all standing
do I have a nomination for chairman of
the committee
Chancellor Jefferson because the Thank
You Costa Barker do I have a seconder oh
because with Hamilton do I have any
other nominations could the committee
therefore all those in favor of cancer
pension being elected chairman anyone
against Jefferson
what does I say you said sorry Council
Jefferson Council Jefferson yeah all
those in favor Council Jefferson Thank
You anyone against that is carried comes
Justin you are now elected chairman
please will you elect your um
vice-chairman I would like to propose
davon Pemberton for vice chair and I'd
like to second Darrin Pemberton was vice
chairman
all those in favor all those in favor
anyone against good either for say that
Darin Pemberton is elected vice chair of
employment and appointments committee
and the meet later next meeting the 9th
of July we then move on to overview and
scrutiny committee can I have the
following counselor standing please
counselor Richards councilor fielding
counselor Cleve house the courteous
counselor Fleming counselor Foreman
counselor iam fragile II counselor
Harris counselor Jennings counselor
Junod and counselor kettle please
[Music]
do I have any nominations for chairman
of the committee council fielding thank
you
so we let me deal with council feelings
of nomination first council fielding who
you're proposing out councillor Richards
thank you
do you have a seconder castle jennings
so we have a proposal and a seconder for
councillor Richards councillor Junaid
I'm proposing a councillor in fragile e
do you have a seconder for that proposal
I second Thank You councillor Cleve we
therefore have two nominations we
therefore need to have a secret ballot
for this election on our last Caroline
to issue papers to all those members of
the committee
right the sake of clarification could
all those voting in the on this make
write the name of the individual on the
piece of paper who they want as chairman
following the secret balance the not
monitoring officers confirmed counsel
Richards is elected there were no
spoiled ballots on pleased to say are
therefore handover to counsel Richard's
chair of the committee to appoint a vice
chair of the committee for 2019-20 Thank
You counsel after that somewhat exciting
starts this year's OSC I do need to seek
a proposer and a seconder for a vice
chair if I may start by proposing
councillor fielding he obviously has
experience in this role so I will seek a
seconder for that please thank you very
much there's been seconded by Councillor
Jennings I do need to seek further
nominations are there any other
nominations councillors unity I'd like
to propose a councillor II in fact
fragile afford any fights Jeff do we
have a seconder councillor Curtis thank
you so we do need to have a vote I don't
believe this to be a secret vote or a
private ballot so we need a show of
hands so if you could have a show of
hands please for council at fielding
five is that five six it's at six sorry
I'm trying to look around everywhere so
we've got six to do that again could you
count from that press because you can
see about the my camp which is
surprising six
and before counselor T and fragile e
please share plans I make that full
sew-in in that case I John fielding has
been canceled John fielding has been
appointed as the vice chairman of the
committee our first meeting was due to
be on Wednesday the 5th of June we were
due to be having some training for
overview and scrutiny but between now
and then that has been postponed so I
have taken the decision to postpone our
first meeting and we will bring all
reports to our meeting of the fourth of
July so that'll be our next meeting
thank you very much take care sir
Richards I now move on to the meeting he
first me to the planning committee a and
call on the executive director okay for
a planning committee egg please can I
have the following counselor standing so
that's counselor Kendall counselor
Richard's counselor Adam counselor
Barnes counselor Dixon counselor Eden
counselor Jennings and counselor Perry
thank you I do have apologies from
councillor Dixon so is there any
substitute
you're not okay thank you
wait do we do I have any nominations for
the chairman of the committee
Richards if I'm a chair I would like to
nominate Danny Kendall do I have a
seconder council Perry do I have any
other nominations the absence of any
nominations of a show of hands in
support of councilor Kendall might
anyone against the council of Kendall
your duly elected chairman of planning
committee a can you please organize the
election of your vice jack you very much
counselor kettle right we move then to
nominations for vice chairman of
planning committee a I'd like to start
by nominating council Richards do I have
a seconder for that counselor Jennings
thank you very much
there are no other nominations all those
in favor of councilor Richards please
show so against abstentions
thank you in that case counselor
Richards thank you you are our vice
chairman as of the information I have
this morning I believe our next meeting
is Wednesday of next week
thank you so I'm an army one planet
committee B which is the call on the
executor I'll call on the executive
director report names those planets or
points of the committee okay can I have
the following counselors standing please
and that's counselor Crump counselor
fielding counselor Fleming counselor
kettle counselor Mills counselor Henshaw
Seraphin counselor Junod and counselor
Barnes please standing
[Music]
right do we have a nomination of
chairman of the committee
Thank You councillor Mills do we have a
seconder councillor Barnes thank you
we have a president second do we have
any other nominations in the absence of
any nominations all those in favor while
councillor Crump as being chair of the
Planning Committee be all those in favor
anyone against council Crump I confirm
your electives are not the chairman of
the Planning Committee be please will
you organize the election of your vice
chairman Thank You mr. chairman I'd like
to nominate Chris Mills for position as
vice chair and I seek a seconder for the
application case the fielding any other
nominations can we vote on temps and
Mills is being voiced yeah all those in
favor against that is carried okay
someone was vice-chair planning
committee be on our next meeting or will
be on Wednesday at the 5th of June thank
you very much
Thank You council cramp and the final
one regulatory committee hand over to
the executive directors report name as
those counselors upon to serve on the
committee
we do have substitute counsel Perry
thank you very much
do I have a nomination for the chairman
of the committee thank you do I have a
seconder I'd like to second councillor
Mills please thank you we've got a
propose around a seconder for councillor
Mills do we have any other nominations
all those in favor of council Mills
being chairman of the committee all
those against that counselor Mills I'm
glad to say you're elected as chairman
of committee would you like to arrange
the election of your vice chairman do
you have a seconder yes I will second
counselor fielding as a set I peanuts
Jeff Cassar Mills Jordan run the
election you've got a proposal in a
seconder all those in favor
sorry right
will they be confirms at future time I'm
sure we therefore need the appointment
of the panel chairman council Mills
so we just we have got your be evolved
into your microphone on paper in - mr.
chairman I like proposed on block the
for licensing committee is John fielding
Chris Mills and Peter Richards and who's
who is the chap okay 303 a chair right
do you have a seconder for that can't
say Perry and you have the nominations
against abstentions for for yeah right
okay I think well I think we're done
you're done I think we call that I call
it a day mr. chairman on thank you very
much that concludes the meetings of
those five different committees which
case I think the business for the annual
meeting is now closed
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
I'd like to welcome you all next door to
celebrate the start the new council as
long as our guests haven't finished them
all this should be a few small eats and
a glass of wine and I'm also reminded by
Beverly hemming that all counselors have
got to report to their photograph taken